[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in lewis riddick he was on
the call for the cowboys win over the
eagles and uh he'll once again be
alongside steve levy brian greasy first
ever monday night wild card game
cardinals rams kick off a week from
today at 8 15 eastern on espn abc and
espn
uh do you want to start with the firings
here naggy in chicago you got mike
zimmer getting fired vic fangio out of
those three jobs which one is the most
attractive
wow man you know
i think chicago obviously because they
have a young quarterback in place
that everyone will say okay well look i
mean every coach right dan you know this
they go into situations going well i'm
gonna be the one who builds it from the
ground up and i'm gonna be the savior
i'm gonna be the next hot thing
i'm gonna be the guy well i mean and
most times they connect that with having
a young quarterback
who they feel as though they can take to
the kind of levels that really are you
know commensurate with being a
championship caliber football team and i
think a lot of people look at justin
feels like that i think the issue in
chicago will be how do they revamp the
front office do they revamp the front
office starting from
like the level right below ownership on
down and how and do they stock it with
football people so to speak although i
don't like necessarily using that term
let me just put it this way that people
who
really do understand what coaches need
in order to be successful what front
offices need to be successful do they do
that if they can do if they do that i
think everybody will be lining up
at the door to try and get that job
minnesota is stopped i heard what you
were just saying this is a good football
team
that's some really good players
that has a they have a system in place
there
in terms of the style of players that
they have that they've that they've
acquired on the offense it's a zone
running team real good running back
all world young wide receiver a
quarterback who can play winning caliber
football but you're right there's going
to be some people who go
but can kirk really be that guy that
postseason guy that can make that can
allow me to
win games at the highest level which is
ultimately what coaches need to do
defensively they got banged up this year
but they still have
people who can rush the passer they got
young fat they got fast aggressive
linebackers they need to revamp the
secondary that's probably right there
that's probably job number two the third
one
you know being denver right now
the issue there is they have no
quarterback
zero
winning caliber defense
still need to continue to build out the
offense but no quarterback at all but in
a great city
a team that right now is go undergoing
obviously some changes from at the
ownership level which will scare off
some people too because you just don't
know how that's going to transition but
i think that's how i would stack them
chicago minnesota denver in terms of
coaches who probably are looking for a
situation where they can really build it
from the ground up those are that's how
i would probably prioritize and then you
throw the giants in there and maybe they
stay with joe judge i mean i'm not here
to lobby for somebody to be fired but if
you're going to replace the gm
it
it just feels like that coach uh could
be in a tenuous situation there and and
i wonder you know
saquon barkley daniel jones
gettleman your gm joe judge it feels
like that might be one big broom that
you use there with the giants uh yeah
your thoughts yeah i i've always thought
then that's the way you should go when
you're doing those kind of things
when you okay when you're trying to
reset an organization and you're trying
to
get your get your footprint operation
back on track it's really hard to
discern okay well whose fault was it
that i need to now make a change was it
the coach
was it the gm
was it the scouts was it the offensive
coordinator was it the special team
what's going on it's hard man and see
right now
everyone excuse my language here but
everyone's in ass covering mode right
now so the gm is going to point to the
coach coach is going to point to the gm
coach is going to point the offensive
coordinator offensive coordinator is
going to point to the defensive
and you know what
that to me is how you erode culture
that's how you erode the concept of team
and honestly when you're resetting a
place you should reset the whole thing
and say this gm and this coach you guys
are together because when it comes to
building out a football operation dan
look you know that it's about
it's about it's about scouting and
evaluation then it's about acquiring
that top valuing that talent and
acquiring it and then it's about
development and utilization and all
three of those things when you're
building a football operation the head
coach and the gm have to be like this
so how can you separate it out then and
go well it's the dm's fault but the
coach is not at fault or it's the
coach's fault but it's not the gm's
fault that's a loser's proposition to me
and i think
they should go as painful as it would be
for the mayors and the tisches to do
that again
is probably what they need to do we're
talking lewis riddick of the mothership
he of course an analyst for monday night
football
brian flores just got fired as the
dolphins head coach oh wow
man things are happening fast man while
i'm sitting here talking
i'm a big fan of brian flores and i'm a
big fan of his and i got to know him a
little bit this year we got to do
you know their game just a couple weeks
ago down in new orleans
they seemed promising but i i as i
mentioned about 15 minutes ago lewis i
was told that if jim harbaugh
you know the raiders would have interest
but the dolphins would be the other team
not the bears and that's what i wonder
now i don't have any information other
than a source said to me yesterday
everybody keep talking about jim maybe
leaving to go to the raiders keep an eye
on the dolphins well i'm watching the
dolphins play and they're beating the
patriots and i thought you know they had
a great second half here
yeah waddle was great you got to decide
on two
yep
see this this is where it doesn't become
it doesn't really become objective at
this point now it just becomes about
subjective and personal desires wishes
feelings wants of the owner
that's really what it comes down to and
owners look they own coaches coach
players play and when owners own they
can do whatever the heck they want and
if you if they have personal feelings
and personal desires to work with
certain individuals
they'll just they don't
well quite honestly they don't have to
justify it to anybody but you don't fire
unless you know who you're gonna hire i
think right is that you know what
yeah you would say that you know i think
in the perfect world yeah
but i don't think
quite honestly i don't think a lot of
owners really think that way anymore
because
yeah they may know who they're gonna
hire who they're gonna try and go after
yeah but i don't always think that they
really think this stuff out really
rationally man i think a lot of this
really happens
emotionally
and i think you know as human beings we
know that sometimes it just becomes
personal it's just about look i don't
want to do this anymore i want to go
this direction
and if you write the checks and you own
the team you can do that and we know
that steven ross has a connection
obviously as being a michigan alum with
with uh coach harbaugh i mean that
that's easy that's an easy connection to
make
and he can throw at him whatever money
he needs to throw at him and give him
total control of the everything so i'm
assuming right now as we're sitting here
talking
chris greer still employed the general
manager
i think so as of right now uh ryan pace
was fired as the gm with the bears two
minutes ago
see there we go yeah see that you know
what though but that's what they needed
to do so now i i i do believe that that
becomes job number one that people would
want now we don't know what's happening
with ted phillips who's also there in
the front office
but i think that becomes job number one
because of justin fields
and down there in miami look you'll find
people who like to some people who don't
some people will want to know what's
going to be the plan as far as that's
concerned are you guys really into
deshaun watson sweepstakes do you like
tua
do you like two yeah i do
if you were the gm of the dolphins
you'd keep tua
i would right now yeah that would be my
plan right now for sure but if you could
get duchaun watson you know what i i
don't i don't know dan look there's a
lot about that that's non-football
related that for me look i just can't
brush off and go well i'm just going to
think about this from a football
perspective in the norm and ignore all
that other stuff you're going down like
an avenue there that has so much unknown
and i'm just not one of those guys who
really believes that you can just
sell your soul just for you know to try
and win football games and kind of just
put on the back burner all those other
things i've never been like that yeah
even in my in all my years in front
office man i used to have some real
heated arguments with people about the
character of certain individuals as it
relates to their football ability and
whether or not they were good fit for
what we were trying to do
i i want to book you for next season
the monday after the final regular
season game 9 20 eastern and then i'll
just tell you all the firings in real
time there you go this is this has been
fun man i mean you're breaking news left
and right
uh i was going to have you on to talk to
you about the chargers strategy here but
uh yeah
i um you know
full disclosure here i i have a problem
that the raiders thought about taking a
knee
and yeah and a tie with a divisional
opponent
like i yeah i don't have any problem
with brandon staley calling a timeout to
change his personnel because i'm
thinking
you want to beat us not right
let's just uh kumbaya man handshake tai
uh yeah i i i agree with you there i
agree the more i think about it more
when i heard his explanation as to what
he was trying to do
i get it he was trying to win the game
if you want to have a problem with
brandon then you should probably rewind
the tape and go back to some other
situations maybe
like going forward on fourth down backed
up in your own territory inside your own
20. i mean maybe you want to get mad at
him get mad at him for that yeah
and plenty of people are yeah
and i can have a problem with that
but don't you want a coach who believes
in you
now you might say he doesn't believe in
his defense therefore he's always going
for it with his offense but i i it feels
like
brandon staley has rubbed the old school
the wrong way
like he's bringing in analytics and hey
we don't need that kind of stuff we have
too much of it in baseball
yeah that there there's there's no doubt
look it this has become something that
has become highly emotional and it's
becoming us versus them type of thing
which
is kind of ridiculous because really the
there there is a sweet spot in the
middle where data is your friend and it
can help you and you do need to be
forward thinking there's no doubt about
that there's no doubt and it's not just
an in-game decision making it's in terms
of kind of structuring your whole
football operation data is powerful it's
a very useful tool useful tool
but man people have really picked side
he's going to be a poster boy like for
being the whipping boy as far as this is
concerned right now yeah i know who
should who should make a change in the
quarterbacking position the colts are
the browns
uh
the colts can't although they should
but they can't
the browns you know what i would ride
with this fifth year option with baker
right now i would until i see what my
next best alternative is i don't think
either look the colts can't make a
change so they're stuck but with the
browns i would hold tight right now
because you've got them next year for
just under 19 million bucks
or for this year and now that we're in
2022 and then you just see how this goes
in the off season and whether or not you
can upgrade the position
great appearance lewis uh
i appreciate it this is this has been
good i mean fast and furious this
morning man fast and furious thank you
buddy uh tell tell leaves and brian we
said hello and uh have fun next uh next
monday night cardinals rams on espn abc
espn plus thank you lewis you bet thank
you that's uh louis riddick espn monday
night football analyst former nfl player
and of course the mother ship will have
the wild card game between the cardinals
and the rams